الاجهزه التابعه لنظام الايراني كل الجهود
وبشتى الطرق للوصول الى المحتاجين وقاده
المظاهرات واعتقالهم مخابرات الشرطه
الايرانيه اعلنت انها اعتقلت اربعه من من
وصفتهم بقاده الاحتجاجات في العاصمه طهران
متهمه اياهم بتعميم الفوضى والتحريض على
شغب
وبحسب الارقام الحقوقيه فان اكثر من
18,500 متظاهر تم اعتقالهم واكثر من 500
متظاهر قتلوا بينهم 69 قاصرا بدورها طلبت
الرابطه الدوليه للاكاديميين الايرانيين
في خطاب المفتوح موجه الى رؤساء الجامعات
بتحديد مرتكبي جرائم قتل الطلاب ومتابعه
اوضاع الطلاب المعتقلين
وقد ورد في البيان ان اكثر من 650 طالبا
اختطفوا على يد قوات الامن والاستخبارات
خلال ال 100 يوم الماضيه وكذا التقرير ان
عناصر الشرطه والامن الايراني طوقوا مرارا
حرام الجامعات بايران وحاصر طلاب وقاموا
احيانا باطلاق النار عليهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جاموسه على راسي